if your app uses background threads for
loading or processing data and pretty
much every app will need those at some
point you might have to take special
precautions to make your UI test run
reliably espresso does most of the heavy
lifting for you waiting for lifecycle
events to finish and checking of the UI
is idle but it can't always know what
the other parts of your app are doing
and you might need to write some
additional code to make synchronization
possible let me show you on an example
I'll create a new project in Android
studio with the empty activity template
let's do some initial setup for testing
I'll add the Android runner rules and
espresso dependencies in my Android test
scope if you're ever unsure what the
newest versions for espresso packages
are consult the documentation or our
testing samples on github which we
always keep up-to-date I didn't set up
the test instrumentation Runner and
we're done here on to the main activity
class the only thing it does right now
is set a layout for the text view let me
open the layout and change that text and
give the textview an ID in onresume I'm
going to change the text and I'll just
quickly extract the string into a
resource for later reuse
let's create a UI test for the activity
using an Android studio shortcut
add the annotation to use the Android
test runner first then I need to set up
the activity test role that will start
my activity
and check if the correct text is
displayed I run the test and it passes
that's because espresso waits until the
app processes all lifecycle events and
I'm setting you the text string in on
resume remember let's simulate a more
realistic scenario where the data takes
some time to load async task is one of
the simplest ways to do background work
and then pass a result back to the main
thread so what happens when I run the
test now surprisingly it passes
that's because espresso also knows how
to synchronize on the async task thread
roll out of the box and because async
tasks are also at the heart of any async
task loader including cursor loaders
they just work of course there's lots of
other ways you can schedule background
work it can be connecting to a remote
API using a custom thread poll or
through handler messaging you can see
I'm changing the code to use a separate
thread which sleeps for five seconds to
simulate background work then post the
change back to the main thread
when I run the test it fails immediately
as soon as onresume returns and the
activity is idle espresso is trying to
validate the message on the textview and
it fails because the runnable hasn't had
a chance to run yet that's when you have
to use iving resource to tell us press o
when your app is busy processing I'll
use an implementation of an idling
resource that we provide with espresso
called counting idling resource it's
very simple to use and it basically lets
you increment the counter for every
resource that is busy when you're
waiting for something to finish loading
and decrement it when it's done espresso
will automatically run whenever the
counter is at zero I'll give it a name
data loader used mostly for logging but
it has to be unique among registered
idling resources now increment before
scheduling my runnable and decrement
when it's done the only thing left is to
register the resource with espresso in
the test class I'll add a setup method
to grab the idling resource instance
from the activity and it's done run
tests after five seconds the counter
gets decremented and the test passes to
sum up if your tests are flaky or
outright failing because of background
threads and synchronous events use
idling resource to tell espresso when to
pause and resume its work that's all for
this episode happy testing